[Applaus]
Putin arbeitet dabei weiter fleißig an
der Spaltung des Westens und sehr
wahrscheinlich auch am Comeback von
Donald Trump dabei hat er Orangen man
weiß Gott genug angerichtet in den USA
nicht zuletzt weil Trump ultra
konservative Richter am Obersten
Gerichtshof platziert hat ist jetzt in
den USA das Recht auf Abtreibung in
akuter Gefahr ja das geht so hervor aus
einem geliebten urteilsentwurf der
wiederum ein berühmtes Urteil aus dem
Jahr 1973 genannt row vs weight kippen
würde ohne das können die Bundesstaaten
schärfere Abtreibungsgesetze erlassen
und zwar bis hin zu einem Komplettverbot
in Texas zum Beispiel sogar nach einer
Vergewaltigung Donald Trump ist trotzdem
wie immer sehr im Reinen mit sich wie
dieses aktuelle Interview beweist for
niemand hat jemals mehr für Religion
getan als Donald Trump und das muss
Jesus dann auch einfach mal akzeptieren
finde ich
sich Prozent der Amerikaner sind für
irgendeine Form von legaler Abtreibung
trotzdem zwingt eine radikale Minderheit
von religiösen Fanatikern dem großen
Rest bald ihr Weltbild auf ich freue
mich schon tierisch auf die
Grußbotschaft vom talibansprecher beim
nächsten super
bowleneu alham liebe Ungläubige
Glaubensbrüder glückwunsch zu eurer
neuen abtreibungsgesetzen die sind echt
super geworden vielleicht noch ein
unverbindlicher Tipp aus Kabul jetzt
bitte euren Frauen auch noch das
Autofahren verbieten denn ohne Auto
kommen sie nicht zur Abtreibungsklinik
in diesem Sinne macht's gut und denkt
auch gelegentlich mal über Steinigungen
für Lesben nach tschüss
wollten sie gerade klatschen
ja willkommen im Gottesstaat USA seit
Jahren besetzt die ihre Trump Sekte
formalinon es Republikaner Gerichte
gezielt mit ihren Leuten und das gerade
gelegte Urteil ist tatsächlich so
formuliert dass zum Beispiel auch das
Recht auf Verhütung wackeln könnte
demnächst was kommt da noch alles es ist
doch der Wahnsinn der Wahnsinn wirklich
26 habt die Serie eigentlich gemacht 26
konservativ regierte Bundesstaaten
planen längst schärfere
Abtreibungsgesetze und Betroffene
müssten dann für eine Abtreibung in
andere Staaten reisen was wiederum für
Frauen aus sozial schwachen Familien ein
riesen Problem wäre meine Theorie
übrigens seit Jahren wenn Männer
schwanger werden könnten gäbs
abtreibungskabinen in Kneipen
ja wobei es natürlich auch verstrahlte
Frauen gibt vor allem bei den
Republikanern
[Musik]
der Moment wenn sogar Gott sich für dich
schämt
Tatsache ist durch Verbote kommt es nie
zu weniger Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen nur
zu gefährlichen illegalen wenn roh vs
Welt kippt blüht Erbsen die in Alabama
Abtreibung durchführen Gefängnis im
Worst Case kein Witz lebenslänglich auch
in Texas drohen Strafen für
medizinisches Personal und für jeden der
bei einer Abtreibung behilflich ist zum
Beispiel für den Taxifahrer der die Frau
zur Klinik fährt und Louisiana plant ein
Gesetz nachdem das Leben schon mit der
Zeugung beginnen würde das heißt zu Ende
gedacht angenommen eine fruchtbare Frau
wird in einer Bar angegraben also sie
bekommt quasi einen großzügiges
zeugungsangebot und lehnt das aber frech
ab womit hier eine Zeugung verhindert
wird macht diese Frau sich strafbar ja
Minimum drei Jahre Knast wegen
unterlassener Befruchtung natürlich
gut man könnte noch erwähnen dass bei
uns in Deutschland Abtreibungen seit
1871 unter Strafe stehen während sogar
das ultrakatholische Irland eine
außerstrafrechtliche Lösung auf die
Kette kriegt aber hey heute schauen wir
einfach nur auf die doofen Amis runter
bei denen droht ein Rollback mindestens
zurück in die 50er mindestens in Florida
gibt es zum Beispiel seit neuestem das
sogenannte don't say gay gesetzt das
verbietet tatsächlich Pädagogen in Kitas
und Grundschulen über sexuelle
Orientierung und Geschlechter Identität
zu sprechen allerdings ist das Gesetz
ganz bewusst so vage formuliert dass es
wohl auch Jugendliche betrifft und weil
der Disney Konzern ja ausgerechnet der
Disney Konzern das don't say gay Gesetz
kritisiert streicht ihm der
republikanische Gouverneur jetzt die
Steuervorteile das tut richtig weh mich
würde es nicht wundern wenn Disney in
Florida bald Mitarbeiter in Schulklassen
schickt um sich zu entschuldigen
Entenhausen one big Swingerclub
gay dogs with no trouser but naked and I
Penis
okay
Snow White and the sevent wars i like to
college Gangbang in the woods
free tickets for the new remastered
version of Disneys classic genau okay
so
und jetzt aber meine ganz andere Frage
was macht eigentlich Markus Söder ja
alle diskutieren über märz oder Günther
als mögliche Kanzlerkandidaten der Union
und Söder kommt gar nicht mehr vor
also außer bei so peinlichen Themen wie
maskenkauf nächstes Jahr ist
Landtagswahl in Bayern und der
Ministerpräsident ist quasi auf dem Weg
zum polit-b-promi nächster Halt
Sommerhaus der Stars also nicht nur dass
er keine Themen mehr setzt ihm geht auch
langsam das Personal aus unglaublicher
Generalsekretär Verschleiß in den
letzten Tagen bei der CSU und Gernot
Hassknecht wittert seine große Chance
gernotasknecht bewirbt sich um einen
neuen Job heute CSU-Generalsekretär
[Musik]
mein Name ist Gernot und ich wäre der
ideale CSU Generalsekretär ich trinke
gerne Bier habe wenig Skrupel und die
Schule fast zu Ende gemacht mit anderen
Worten im Vergleich zu Stefan Meier bin
ich quasi überqualifiziert nach neun
Wochen raus Augen weil er einem bunte
Reporter folgendes ins Telefon gebrüllt
hat ich werde sie vernichten ich werde
sie ausfindig machen ich verfolge sie
bis ans Ende ihres Lebens ich verlange
200.000 Euro Schmerzensgeld die müssen
Sie mir noch heute überweisen
eine Penisverlängerung
CSU-Generalsekretär diese Stelle ist für
mich wie gemalt schon erlisten
anschreien will durch die Gegend
schnackseln für uneheliche Kinder nicht
bezahlen das sind alles meine
Kernkompetenzen ehrlich gesagt keine
normale Firma würde mich jemals nehmen
aber die CSU ist eben keine normale
Firma wie diese erschütternden Bilder
beweisen das Genie hier der bayerische
Räuber Hotzenplotz hat Stefan Meier
persönlich ausgesucht um dann nach gut
zwei Monaten sagen zu müssen auf
Nimmerwiedersehen ja okay wir haben uns
alle schon mal in Menschen getäuscht
passiert und der markus hat ja
blitzschnell reagiert und direkt den
nächsten Top-Mann aus dem bescheuerten
riesenhut gezaubert Martin Huber dazu
muss man wissen die Hälfte der
CSU-Mitglieder heißt entweder Meier oder
Huber es schwer zu erklären hat auch mit
Inzest zu tun ist aber gar nicht das
Thema entscheidend ist der markus hat
nach einem einmaligen Griff ins Klo
jetzt endlich den idealen Mann gefunden
ein Experte will in seiner Doktorarbeit
zahlreiche Zitate ohne oder mit falscher
Quellenangabe gefunden haben uber hatte
am Freitag die Nachfolge von Stefan
Meier angetreten
[Gelächter]
schöne ich erwarte bis morgen früh
deinen Anruf und denkt daran ich habe
noch zig andere Angebote hallo mein Name
ist Gernot hasknecht und ich bewerbe
mich auf die freiwerdende Stelle als
Verteidigungsministerin ich habe null
Ahnung von Militär aber ich komme abends
oft besoffen aus der Kneipe und find
mein Auto nicht mehr dann soll mich
gefälligst ein Hubschrauber abholen
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekanntgeben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten